ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung im
seminarpolitische Philosophie heute
wollen wir ihr ein Blick auf die
historischen Dimension werfen es geht
vor allem um Klassiker der politischen
Philosophie wir beginnen chronologisch
mit Platon die es ein Bild von ihm aus
Stein und Platon hat das
Werk politea verfasst
zu deutsch der Staat es ist sein
Hauptwerk es ist sehr umfangreich
besteht aus vielen Unterteilungen und in
diesen Wert stellt Platon unter anderem
muss man sagen die Frage nach dem
idealen Staat
trotz allem zentrieren sich die Fragen
letztendlich auf diese Frage hin nach
dem idealen Staat und Platon hat jetzt
hier eine ganz wirkmächtige Theorie das
idealen Staates entwickelt nämlich die
Idee des philosophenkönigs der
Philosophen Könige das jetzt voraus dass
der ideale Staat aus drei
Bevölkerungsgruppen oder Klassen besteht
und diesen Bevölkerungsgruppen werden
verschiedene menschliche Eigenschaften
sehe sogenannte seelenvermögen und auch
Tugenden Tugenden also Formen des
gutseinsformen des gelingenden Lebens
zugeordnet und wir werfen jetzt mal
Blick auf diese Unterscheidung ganz oben
mit diesem idealen Staat stehen die
Herrscher die Philosophen Königin wird
das Vermögen der Vernunft zugeordnet und
das führt zu Tugend der Weisheit jede
Klasse hat ihre eigene Erkenntnistheorie
sie ihre eigene seelenvermögen und ihre
eigene Tun danach kommen die Wächter den
wird das Vermögen des Willens genauer
genommen das Mutes zugesprochen und die
haben dann die tugende Tapferkeit wenn
Sie Ihr Vermögen auf die richtige Weise
gebrauchen und ganz zum Schluss
meistens BewohnerInnen Bewohner dieses
die allen Staates sind
bauernhandwerker der sogenannte nähr
stand also die Menschen die arbeiten die
für die Ernährung sorgen den wird das
Vermögen des Begehrens
begehrungsvermögen auch er seinen
empirisches sinnliches Vermögen
zugesprochen also was was recht
unreflektiert ist und die Tugend dieses
Vermögens ist die Besonnenheit also die
richtige Mitte
im begehren
zu Tage zu legen jetzt gibt es hier ein
interessantes Zitat aus der Politiker
welches die Grundidee dieses Buches sehr
kompakt enthält ist man vor wenn ich in
den Staaten entweder die Philosophen
Könige werden oder die welche man jetzt
Könige und Herrscher nennt echte und
gründliche Philosophen werden und wenn
nicht diese beiden die politischen Macht
und die Philosophien eins zusammenfallen
und alle die vielen Natur und die heute
ausschließlich nach dem ein oder dem
anderen Streben zwingend ausgeschlossen
werden dann gibt es kein Ende der übel
für die Staaten und wie ich meine auch
nicht für die Menschheit ganz zentral
die Passage habe ich fit markiert
politische Macht und Philosophie fallen
im idealen Staat zusammen deswegen sind
auch die Philosophen diejenigen die den
Staat beherrschen durch ihre Vernunft
und Weise man kann jetzt natürlich
Platon da ein Idealismus vor werfen der
nichts mit der Realität zu tun hat das
haben auch viele getan man kann auch
verschiedenes kritisieren dass
tatsächlich nicht nur Philosophen und
philosophenen Herrscher sein sollten
sondern Menschen die vielleicht auch
gerade mehr Bodenhaftung haben um so die
Welt im Gesellschaft besser zu kennen
Philosophen so sagt man häufig befinden
sich im
Elfenbeintürmen also das kann man hier
alles sehr kritisch untersuchen
weiter geht es jetzt mit einem nächsten
Philosophen das ist jetzt am Aristoteles
und er hat auch einen interessantes Buch
verfasst nämlich das Buch mit dem Titel
Politik von altgriechischen Politiker
die politischen Dinge und darin sind
seine politische Philosophie enthalten
eine Polis was ist das eine Police ist
ein gesetzlich geregelter Verbund von
Personen
oder Bürgern also es geht darum wie eine
Stadt eine Gemeinschaft zu der für uns
zugehörig fühlen ein Mensch ist nach
Aristoteles ein Zorn politikon ein
politisches Lebewesen so heißt das ein
Lebewesen dessen Lebensform
gemeinschaftlich ausgerichtet ist der
Mensch ist als solche ein Gemeinschaften
immer schon lebender oder auf
Gemeinschaften hin Streben des Wesen
also die politische Lebensform ist die
eigentlich menschliche Lebensform gibt
es hier noch eine sehr interessante
Übersicht über seine verschiedenen
Herrschaftsformen die unterscheidet man
sieht hier er unterscheidet die
Herrschaftsformen dahingehend ob es nur
eine Person ist die herrscht ob es
wenige sind oder viele und jeweils
unterscheidet er davon ausgehend eine
gelingende Herrschaftsform und eine
scheiternde Herrschaftsform eine
defizitäre eine problematische Form und
die Frage richtet sich danach ob die
Herrschaftsform auf das Gemeinwohl
ausgerichtet ist oder auf den eigennutzt
das ist hier die Frage
wir sehen hier dass
die Monarchie ganz klar positiv
konnotiert ist die Türen nein gegen
negativ interessant ist sie jetzt das
die Demokratie die ja für uns die
positivste Form der politischen
Regelung der politischen Ordnung
darstellt für ihn gerade auf den
Eigennutz ausgerichtet ist
und die Politik also die vernünftige
viel Herrschaft auf das Gemeinwohl das
ist sicherlich erstmal irritierend
weiter geht es in unserem Konzept mit
einem Philosophen der
Renaissance Nicolo maccerelli er hat ein
Buch verfasst mit dem Titel
der Fürst und hier geht es um
die Frage wie wir macht am besten
erhalten und sichern und verteidigen
ganz interessant ist das für materielle
nicht so sehr die Frage nach Gemeinwohl
im Zentrum steht sondern eher um den
Eigennutz man spricht deswegen auch von
einem disputismus oder von Tyrannei nach
Aristoteles wäre das ein Tyrann dieser
Fürst als ein sehr provokatives Werk
eine weitere Figur ist Thomas auch sehr
sehr zentral der sich mit der Frage
befasst hat
wie wir gemeinsam so leben können dass
wir uns nicht mehr Schaden
er steht vor dem Hintergrund des
englischen Bürgerkriegs im 17
Jahrhundert und dadurch ist sein
Menschenbild sehr negativ geprägt worden
und er verfasste deswegen diese
schriftleviata
Leviathan bezeichnet diese Person die
man im Hintergrund sieht die vereint die
weltliche Macht und die kirchliche Macht
symbolisiert durch Schwert und Bischof
starb und nur diese Leviathan dieser
Staat ist in der Lage uns aus diesem
Naturzustand zu bringen und wir können
das dadurch tun dass wir dem Leviathan
alle unsere Macht übertragen und es
sieht man daran wenn man genau hinschaut
dass diese Körper dieses leviat hat
dieses Herrschers hier aus lauter
kleinen Personen besteht das ist sein
eine Kollektiv Person die durch viele
einzelne Personen deren vertraglich
geregelte Macht über tragen zustande
kommt
ja das ist natürlich ein sehr sehr
zentrale Entwurf
diese Idee der Kollektiv Person die Idee
des Vertrages wurde in der Folge
mehrmals wieder aufgegriffen
zum Beispiel durch jean-jacroissant
einem sehr bedeutenden Philosophen der
Aufklärung er hat ein Buch geschrieben
das heißt der Gesellschaftsvertrag schon
Titel sieht man das und diese
Gesellschaftsvertrag ist eine Form von
Demokratie und so unterscheidet zwischen
gemeinwille und Wille aller
im Gemeinwesen wird dass wir uns darauf
einigen auf vernünftige Weise
dasjenige zu tun was wir immer schon
wollen während der Wille Allah nach wozu
ein Wille ist der nur aus individual
Willen besteht dadurch können wir nach
und so keine wirkliche Freiheit und auch
keine wirkliche
stabile politische Ordnung erzeugen
ein weiterer wichtiger Philosoph den wir
nicht vernachlässigen dürfen ist
Immanuel Kant Immanuel Kant ist ebenso
Virus so ein Philosoph der Aufklärung er
hat ein wichtiges Werk verfasst und den
Titel zum ewigen Frieden singer 1795 da
war kann schon über 70 Jahre alt und es
geht ihm wieder Titel schon sagt um die
Frage wie wir einen ewigen Frieden
zwischenstaaten Nationen sichern können
diese Frage ist natürlich zeitlos ein
absoluter Klassiker immer wieder erhält
diese Frage politische Relevanz kann
denkt dabei bereits globale
Gerechtigkeit an und zu etwas wie ein
Kosmopolitismus also eine weltbürgerung
spielt für ihn eine Rolle er denkt
Gerechtigkeit politische Gerechtigkeit
nicht nur mit Blick auf einzelne Staaten
sondern Blick auf alle Staaten die
gesamte Menschheit
Karl Marx um einen zeitlichen Sprung zu
machen ein Philosoph des späteren 19
Jahrhunderts hat ein Werk verfasst mit
dem Titel das Kapital aus dem Jahr 1867
dass ich als Kritik der politischen
Ökonomie versteht darin nähert sich Marx
wie der Titel schon sagt über die
Wirtschaftsverhältnisse der Politik und
der politischen Gerechtigkeit an das ist
ein ganz interessanter Zugang nicht über
vertragstheorien nicht über die andere
Politik nicht über Menschen
Verfasstheit wie bei Thomas Herbst auch
nicht
angesichts der menschlichen Vermögen und
Tugenden wie Platon sondern über die
Wirtschaft das ist eine neue Zugang er
kritisiert die Rolle der Arbeiter im
Kapitalismus und die Kapitalisten auf
der anderen Seite und die zuständig dazu
führen dass die Schere zwischen Arm und
Reich immer weit auseinander geht also
es geht um ökonomische Ungerechtigkeit
das
Ziel die Utopie wie auch immer man es
nennen soll das Kommunismus ist eine
klassenlose Gesellschaft in der die
Produktionsmittel allen zur Verfügung
stehen und nicht monopolisiert sind das
sieht nämlich Max als das Grundübel und
die politische grundgerechtigkeit an
ich möchte auch auf Hannah Arendt
eingehen eine ganz zentrale wichtige
aktuelle politische Philosophen des 20
Jahrhunderts seit ein Werk geschrieben
unter anderem Elemente und ursprünglich
totaler Herrschaft man sieht hier schon
auf diesem Bild das natürlich eine
neuere Ausgabe ist nicht die
Originalausgabe
Menschen die dem Nationalsozialismus
anhängen und der Nationalsozialismus
spielt auch eine große Rolle sie selbst
hat ihn erlebt im eigenen Leibe und sie
kritisiert totalitäre Systeme also
Systeme die absolute Gültigkeit
voraussetzen und auch absolute Geltung
verlangen absolutes Gehorsam verlangen
und auch speziell die Ideologien solche
politische Systeme den Ideologien tragen
nach einer Abend dazu bei dass wir unser
politisches Handel nicht mehr kritisch
hinterfragen mehr noch die tragen dazu
bei dass wir unser Handeln zunehmend
radikalisieren und dann auch wie
Nationalsozialismus geschehen und
menschliche Verbrechen
begehen
an Aachen die sicherlich sehr zentral
ich möchte auf einen anderen ebenso
zentralen Denker nach Hinweisen Michelle
fukode noch ein bisschen jünger ist als
Hannah Arend der sich vor allem mit
Diskursen befasst hat ein Diskurs ist
also eine Formation des Sprechens aber
nicht nur der Kommunikation sondern der
Macht Ausübung durch sprechen oder
genauer durch die Art und Weise wie man
über bestimmte Dinge sprechen soll oder
sprechen muss und diese Dinge über die
gesprochen wird über die sich die
Diskurse drehen die diese Diskurse
betreffen das sind vor allem politische
Unterscheidungen aber auch
Unterscheidungen wie Wahnsinn und
Sexualität
genauso auch an sowas wie Gefängnisse
sind für ihn Orte an den politischen
Macht Diskurse sehr deutlich zu Tage
getreten und es geht ihm darum diese
Diskurse aufzudecken und zu kritisieren
also das ist sicherlich auch ein sehr
sehr zentraler Philosoph so ich habe
jetzt einige natürlich lange nicht alle
politischen Philosophen Philosophen hier
mal kurz vorgestellt und ich bedanke
mich für die Aufmerksamkeit